hey I'm Hailee Steinfeld and I am doing
a wired autocomplete interview Oh scared
no not except let's go first question is
how is Hailee Steinfeld I don't really
know how to answer this I'm how how am i
yeah I'm good how tall is Hailee
Steinfeld this is where I lie and say
five seven was Hailee Steinfeld in Harry
Potter no is that like do people think
good yes what is Hailee Steinfeld doing
now currently right this second I am
sitting here talking to you do says
Hailee Steinfeld have a child not that
I'm aware of
I do not have a child does Hailee
Steinfeld write her own songs I do music
is a huge huge part of my life and I
love that I'm able to use that as an
outlet of self-expression in a way that
I don't necessarily or can't really do
in my acting my music is is me and it's
only getting more real so I'm very
excited for people to hear how much of
myself is in these new songs so Hailee
Steinfeld have siblings I have one older
brother and he is quite possibly the
best older brother on the planet his
name is Griffin he is 25 and truly my
best friend and has been the greatest
role model in my life you get to sort of
watch your older sibling go through life
and make mistakes and learn from them so
that you don't necessarily make the same
ones and that's kind of an amazing thing
and an unfortunate thing for them in a
sense but he is so wonderful and has
sacrificed so much for me to be able to
do what I love and is just so supportive
and Griffin I love you that's about all
the nice things I'll say about you for
the rest of the year
does hailee steinfeld have her ears
pierced she does now people okay I just
got them fierce for the first time a
couple months ago my mom wanted me to be
old enough to make my own decision about
getting them pierced so when I became
old enough to decide I decided that I
was too indecisive so I guess I got to a
point where I was kind of waiting for
somebody to tell me I had to but I woke
up one day and was like I'm ready I'm on
the Pierce Myers I need a little change
in my life you know saying it's a little
spicy so I'm when Pierce my hair is so
rebellious I know does Hailee Steinfeld
have tattoos secrets just kidding no I
don't have any tattoos I love tattoos
though if I found something that I found
incredibly meaningful to me I would do
it for sure
love the idea of it what color is Hailee
Steinfeld's hair brown light ish dark
some people say it's dark and I've never
colored it fun fact
what does Hailee Steinfeld sing she
sings this a really great song right now
called
afterlife which is a part of the show
called Dickinson
that I'm incredibly excited about that
I've been working on for I have no sense
of time but a while and it's finally out
there about to be in the world which is
insane
what was Hailee Steinfeld first movie
true grit I was 13 years old when I made
that film and it was the absolute time
of my life the Coen brothers are I have
no words to describe them they are the
ultimate that cast was absolutely
incredible I could not think of a better
first movie experience it was and is
hearted hard to be right before
everybody was about to go away for
Christmas vacation I started working
with my coach on the material in the
hopes of getting an audition if not I
was preparing to make a tape and send it
in and sure enough I was called in at
the end of the end of break and I had
was prepared because I've been working
on it because my momma told me to and
then I went in I had three auditions
over the course of I think a month and
then after my last audition a week later
I was on a plane and I was in the middle
of nowhere shooting a movie called True
Grit what was Hailee Steinfeld's first
song loved myself and that song
represents self love and self confidence
and that sort of self reassurance I was
so happy that it was a song that not
only was a message I could give to my
fans but a reminder to myself especially
during that time of like jumping into
the music space because that was that a
little scary what languages does Hailee
Steinfeld speak I wish I spoke languages
other than my own other than English in
my own language that I speak with myself
in my head let's go
it is Hailee Steinfeld related to Jerry
Seinfeld no unfortunately you see there
is a minor difference here there is a
team missing okay so no relation
unfortunately just admiration is Hailee
Steinfeld Canadian I wish I love
Canadians is Hailee Steinfeld married to
Justin Bieber classic makes up no I'm
not Hailee Bieber is married to Justin
Bieber is Hailee Steinfeld vegan I am
NOT vegan I have quite a few friends
that are I'm all for it if you are vegan
you fully support it I think that's
great
yeah is Hailee Steinfeld nice no she's a
nightmare I do not recommend if you can
avoid any encounters with her definitely
do it okay
when is Hailee Steinfeld's birthday
December 11th Sagittarius I do feel like
a pretty true sad I'm learning a lot
more about my sign as I get older and
and I do find that there are you know
there are a few things that are off but
for the most part it's pretty accurate
which is scary and then I do find that
whenever I am Andrew
said in a guy I immediately go to our
Sagittarius women compatible with blank
and I read up on it and I definitely
follow if it's not skirt
no one was Hailee Steinfeld born so
December 11 1996 lil Hailee Steinfeld
feet in bumblebee - is their bumblebee -
that I don't know about because if there
is I better be in it if Hailee Steinfeld
win lip sync battle yes she did people
that was so fun I am obsessed with that
show and think it's so great the way
they like fully fully go for it is so
exciting it's like a full-on production
it's basically what I aspire for my own
personal shows to look like but we did a
live lip-sync battle and it was so
exciting I was actually very very sick
and had no voice so the irony of it
being a lip-sync battle I was so
prepared to prepared I lost my voice
whose Hailee Steinfeld
does anybody know it's a great question
who is Hailee Steinfeld's best friend I
have a handful of very close friends I
mentioned one before is my brother and
my parents but I do have some wonderful
people in my life that I have known for
my whole life that are just rad people
that I'd like to be around so yeah shout
out to you guys you know who you are
who does Hailee Steinfeld look like do I
look like anybody anybody do it spit it
out
I look like me okay when I was younger I
I got Brooke Shields kinda every now and
then which I mean huge massive
compliment I look like my mom did Hailee
Steinfeld play guitar and begin again I
did play guitar I shot that film in in
New York City actually which is so much
fun and I did play guitar in the film I
had about I want to say like a
week of rehearsals for it I just
remember being incredibly nervous
because I felt like I was you know we
were on a rooftop in New York City of
filming a movie but like filming a scene
that we were performing live and it was
a very big deal and I was so excited
about it but very very nervous but it
worked because the character was nervous
so came natural and yeah I loved I loved
playing the guitar did Hailee Steinfeld
win an Oscar no no but I was nominated
when I was 14 years old which is insane
I don't know how I did that the coolest
part about that whole experience is no
one that I made that project with was
concerned about winning anything it was
just about getting together and creating
a creating art I am incredibly honored
that I received that that that on earth
and home nation um but yeah I don't know
I get to do what I love I get to wake up
every day and be around cool people that
inspire me so that feels like a big win
to me
I'm Hailee Steinfeld this was so much
fun thank you for googling me and yeah
hope it cleared some things up there